our guest today is writer director kyle
patrick alvarez who made headlines at
the 2010 independent spirit awards with
the someone to watch award along with a
nomination for best first feature
regarding his film easier with practice
easier with practice stars brian garrity
as a confused young man embarking on a
cross-country road trip with his slick
younger brother to promote his
unpublished novel while dealing with a
sultry female caller played by katie
azelton who prefers late night sex calls
to a real relationship the film has won
numerous awards at festivals such as
cinevegas and the edinburgh film
festival kyle is currently slated to
direct two other features girls and cog
please welcome to this episode of film
courage mr kyle patrick alvarez hello
hello welcome thank you for having me
great to have you here on the super bowl
sunday yes indeed
thank you for delaying your super bowl
activities
yeah it made me it actually made me feel
good to have a reason not to watch
because i always feel guilty yeah i had
to remind myself last night who was even
in the game so i'm with you there
what was life like for you growing up um
i uh while i was born in miami i grew up
a lot as a i mean i grew up a lot i
obviously grew up um i moved around a
lot as a kid uh so i you know lived in
europe for a while in canada for a while
and kind of settled in northern
california for for high school and such
and always loved film as a kid um but i
was never really one of those kids that
has like a video camera in their
backyard i never really made films i
just watched a lot so i would go to
blockbuster and like stock up on 10 vhs
tapes or you remember that like the
movie was really long it would have like
the double case where they put the
rubber bands between them you know i'd
always have those and and just spend
like weekends watching movies and then
once dvds came out just started
listening to audio commentaries a lot
and
really doing that sort of early film
school kind of thing
um in terms of
being aware of what was out there and
trying to become sort of a cinephile and
then i went to
film school in my went back to miami for
film school
and went there for uh four years and got
my um you know my bachelor's and film
and literature having grown up in the
bay area myself i know that creativity
is definitely encouraged there and i'm
wondering did your parents foster that
or did they want you to go to school for
more something like medicine or law oh
no they were always really i my mom
might be listening right now so she is
i'm saying hi and i'm also telling the
truth even if she is listening they were
always really um encouraging i can't
think of a moment in my life that
uh ever once uh you know that they were
like well maybe this or maybe that there
was never any deferment and um i you
know you hear the stories of the people
that that do have that kind of
difficulty from their parents or or
their support system and and it's i
can't even imagine i mean for me it was
just oh it was never like i never had to
think twice about it and moving out to
la i never had to think twice about it
was always a lot of encouragement and
going to school for it and and um if
anything the only roadblocks were my own
you know just being like maybe am i
nervous am i taking on too much am i you
know that kind of thing but they were
they've always been very supportive so
you know i'm still just loving the fact
that we have kyle here in the studio you
know this is fantastic
um kyle which of these traits would you
say rates higher in your dna
luck or hard work
hard hard work
hard work definitely hard work i mean i
think i can't remember the quote or who
said it but it's like luck is the
combination of hard work and patience or
hard work and you know and it's like
building that
trying i've always thought and i haven't
been in los angeles too long yet but
i've always thought okay what what can i
do there's so many people out here
trying to do the same thing so what can
i do to try to you know it was like okay
a lot of people move out to la okay well
not everyone who moves out has a script
or not everyone who moves out has a film
and like all of that just trying to be
like okay i really just want to keep on
working and trying hard to do that but
at the same time um
i'd be you know lying if i said that
good things didn't you know i mean it
was a lot of its timing and you know
fine even finding brian for the for the
lead of our film and
and him being the right guy and
six months later they're hurt you know
six months after our movie plays the
hurt locker winning best picture that
kind of thing like none of us knew that
was gonna happen so some of those things
like that that help bring attention and
exposure um
are sheer luck and you can't really plan
for them you can just sort of set the
path to hope for that kind of luck so
and you know you mentioned sort of
becoming a cinephile you mentioned go to
the university of miami for film school
but at what point did you know
like this is something i want to do like
i want to be a filmmaker
you know i can
it's usually in editing it's never in
production you know so i can remember
even when i was making my first film i
mean to say oh i always wanted to make
films it's like okay i always wanted to
be in film
and i think ever you know your natural
inclination to say oh i want to write
and direct but you know you don't really
know until you do it if you really
really like it and um i remember my
first film the production was like it
was just like two two of us and we had
to like shoot on one of those like three
lens bowlexes and it was like film and
it was it was we had to spool the film
it was so complicated we had all these
extras and and it was really like
stressful like the three days we shot
the movie on and i just remember being
like super overwhelmed by it but then
when we had the the footage and editing
and we were like putting it together and
it's like the first time you actually
see like a continuity it's like the most
simple things were like so exciting to
be like oh he reached through the frame
and then we cut to the insert and you
see the hand and it grabs the watch and
it was those kind of things where it was
like this is works like a real movie and
it was i remember that being like oh and
i'm still that way like i still just
look forward to the day of being in the
editing suite and like putting it
together you know the production is
always
can be so challenging and stressful and
it's sometimes it's nice to just end up
back in the dark room like the same room
where you wrote the script and then back
there being okay we have this footage
and every time i get there i'm always so
so happy and um and i love production
too but i can remember on my first film
when we started cutting i was like okay
i actually really like that i love do it
it's playing around but can be it can be
a career sometimes so
let's go back to your arrival in la
what were your notions coming here did
you
did you plan out what were you going to
do or were you simply thinking you know
what i'm just going to come to la and
kind of land something i don't know what
it is but i'll find it are you
uh by the seat of your pants kind of guy
are you more a methodical planner i'm
i'm now more methodical now i'm like
okay i'm trying to think like four films
ahead i'm trying to like lay out as much
as i can when i first moved out there
here i had a little bit you know i i
come from
you know i my parents are immigrants and
we grew up always working you know it's
my mindset has always been you work
really hard you work every day you know
that's and that's how i am but in some
ways the film industry isn't like that
you don't really
work your way up in some some ways you
don't you know unless you're going to
try to be a producer or an agent then
yeah you start as an assistant you work
your way up maybe not even a producer
nowadays but you know in that way you do
and that way it follows a traditional
business mold but as you guys know you
just have to go and actually make
something it's the only way that you
have to go from step one to step a
hundred but i didn't my natural
inclinations were i'm gonna move out to
la i'm gonna get whatever job i can it's
gonna be getting my foot in the door and
and i would still encourage people to do
that but to also know your limits
because i was a runner
for like so i moved out here i just you
know didn't have a job or anything and
and um got a job as like a runner for a
production company
and for six months i was basically just
in my car all day long picking up film
at fedex i mean at the fedex like at the
airport like i had to wait for the plane
to come in and watch the film because
they're shooting in new york by
processing it here and i have to drive
from lax all the way back into hollywood
back to the production office's back i
was like wait a second i'm not even
you know it wasn't it wasn't the kind of
office where they were gonna be like oh
you paid your dues now we're gonna give
you this step up and i i had other
people that i knew that worked there for
a long time and and now you know you
have to be some that some people get
that kind of job where the your boss is
great and they want to see you succeed
and they they don't want to just it's
this weird thing where like if you're a
really good assistant sometimes they get
really comfortable with you being a good
assistant and don't want to lose you and
i i get that but on some ends there's
but you hear other stories they're
totally different but for me my first
job as a runner i was just i'm not
learning anything and it was it was a
little abusive and
um i mean not like physically abusive
but it was like i was coming home like i
was coming home like just depressed
and so i um
and so i left i left that job and it was
the first time i'd ever quit anything in
my life
um you know it was like a year
commitment and after six months i was
just like i can't do this this is by the
end of this i won't be happy
um and that was actually a really smart
thing that i did and then it was really
good for me because it was it was like a
standards thing it was like no i i want
to do
more than this i want more
experience or exposure and i'm not
saying oh quit your job i'm just saying
know when
your foot is in the door to nudge the
door open or if it's just getting hot
and sort of slammed against the door and
um and my second job was
i i got i was an assistant for warren
beatty and that was a much better
experience i mean that i mean totally
different world of
you know of what i was learning and the
experience i was getting versus the work
i was putting in and that was the next
question how did you end up going for
that job and how did you get this
assistant job for for warren beatty um
sherlock once again talking about hard
work and luck i mean it was i knew
someone that uh
was an old friend of his and they
introduced me and he was it was timing
you know he was looking for someone to
do some do some work for him and um and
it worked out well and i i spent exactly
a year
uh working for him um in all facets and
doing all different types of stuff and
it was a really good experience just to
kind of understand how
the hierarchy works you know in
hollywood and um
who controls the studio you know how the
studios are controlled and not in a that
sounds paranoid not in a conspiracy kind
of way but just just how few people
really have a say in those huge movies
we see the big movies that we go to you
know the trons and the inceptions and
everything and like who are the who is
that small sandbox of people that really
make those decisions that guide the the
primary aspects of the industry it was
really interesting
so from from doing background on your
story now you're this assistant and then
you have this burning desire to make a
movie and i understand you hand in your
two weeks notice
and and you're not even sure
kind of what you're going to do in that
span of time yeah so i gave my two weeks
notice and i was just like i just knew i
wanted to make a film i was like even if
i can just whatever whatever it might be
and this is you know pre-kickstarter pre
uh pre all these sort of financing
options but it was just like i just know
that i need to sort of throw myself down
the pit because if not it's just not
gonna happen i needed to need to make it
not just for my own desires but like to
survive and and so um i yeah i left my
job without a specific sense of like oh
what movie i wanted to make but
somewhat by luck or chance um i'd never
read gq magazine in my life before and i
had some subscription like a gift
subscription to some magazine that was
condensed that got i mean this is
bringing it back to luck and hard work
and it got cancelled and so they've
filled in like the last three months of
my subscription with gq you know just
like hey we're sorry we this this
magazine went under but here's gq to
make up for it and um
and i remember it was august 2006 and it
was justin timberlake on the cover the
magazine i remember like i don't even
know what this magazine isn't opening up
and there was this article in there and
i read it and i read it again
and i just i i loved it right away and
maybe it was that pressure i'd put in
myself where i was like oh god i'm
leaving in two weeks i don't have a job
what am i going to do
um but i was like this is really
something i could see it was the first
time i felt
confident like i was like i know how to
make this story into a movie and i know
how to make it into what i feel would
have been a good movie and i'd never
felt that before about about a story so
it was really enlightening for me
i want to read something that we found
in indie wire and you say
that you had this epiphany when you read
the story in gq and you said it was a
surreal moment in which i suddenly felt
an immense amount of confidence about
how to tell the story cinematically and
also this specific determination to get
it done i was 23 at the time and i set a
goal for myself to be on set and making
the film by the time i turned 25. i mean
that's that's amazing to me what what
type of
motivational prep work
you know it was going in your head at
age 23 and where did this gumption come
from
you know i just
i really felt you know i'd learned that
from the from the runner job and the
assistant job and i know people who've
worked much longer and much harder you
know in those kind of jobs than i did so
i have so much respect for them and for
me it was kind of okay i knew i had to
like i said go from step one to kind of
step a hundred and it was for me it was
like i knew i could tell the story in a
range of
prices you know budgets um
we ended up
with a relatively healthy budget um
which was good because i had specific
aesthetic things i wanted to do that
just take money to do in terms of
shooting in cars and shooting on the
road and so many things but i also was
prepared to tell the story with pocket
change too if i needed to and
that was why i sort of set that goal
like i took by by the time i'm 25
because i was like if i'm 25 and i'm not
making this yet i don't really have much
of a reason to not be making it because
i could go do this just with like a
camera and you know sound guy and and
some actors and so um
it ended up not being that but i
realized setting setting deadlines
is
in some ways is kind of important
because then everyone else takes the
project more seriously they're like oh
it's real it's going to happen and you
know you don't want to ever lie and be
like oh it's going to usually say things
i wanted to do that's my plan you know
it's my it's my plan to
to shoot it in six months okay so what
are we gonna do and even if you don't
make that plan at least people around
you start realizing that you're serious
about it want to do it yeah i mean you
know how they say you you put out your
your goal and the the universe conspires
to bring it in without sounding too you
know
you know uh new age here but it almost
sounds too easy in some sense because
it's like
the amount of people that come here in
droves and they work so hard for years
and and and it sounds wonderful that
here you get this great job as an
assistant even
you know i know how hard it is i've
looked for jobs on craigslist and it's
like you don't find those jobs listed
there you know and and and then to to
give that two weeks notice and have that
happen i mean that's really really
amazing well and you know i i really do
feel lucky because i mean i've i know
that our our film could have disappeared
into complete obscurity and i don't say
that in a self-deprecating way i just
say that like i've seen plenty of films
that i've loved that have you know i
mean i programmed a film festival this
year and was fortunate enough to sit on
the board of the summer watch award that
i s that i won last year so i get to
watch all these films and some were
films you know that don't have
distribution yet they don't have any
level of exposure yet and not that we
you know
we didn't get to play any we didn't play
sundance or tribeca or new york film
festival we didn't play any big
festivals but we still got
a lot of exposure especially coming to
the spirit awards and and i realized
that you know that i know that that
could have easily not have happened for
us i know that a lot of that was just
luck you know
a lot of it was the hard work we put
into making a film we were proud of but
another part of it was just the right
people seeing it at the right time and
that may not have happened with that and
i know some people that it doesn't
happen until their fourth or fifth film
and
um and it might still take me another
four or five to you know i mean i'm the
i'm not necessarily a
you know in a place where i have the
offers coming in from studios yeah i
mean it's one of those things where i
really um it's still a lot of it's still
a lot of hard work and and yeah i i'm
definitely grateful and don't uh don't
take it for granted that people got to
see the film is there anything you want
to say to those filmmakers you know
you're watching their films they don't
have distribution is there anything that
you wish you could just say to those
guys um i would say just keep on keep on
making films that's what i'm trying to
do you know it's just like i just want
to um
even though some of my favorite
filmmakers you know are the ones that
only made a handful of films in their
lifetime that the stanley kubrick's and
terence malik well he's catching up now
but i mean he uh you know those guys
that i that i love so much i know for me
and the place i'm in it's like in the
kind of work i want to do i know i'm
going to end up being one of those guys
hopefully one of those guys that makes
like a movie all the time you know like
is always making someone like woody
allen who's always making a film and
they're not they're not always his best
work but you kind of respect the fact
that he's he's a workman at the end of
the day and and um it's just two
different paths and so i i mean i always
encourage the people that you know
unless you have the patience and the
income uh you know take you know just
keep on just keep on trying to make them
because
i mean perseverance always wins out you
know it's about you know actors and and
filmmakers in this city um
always work everyone works so hard and
some people it's it hits them early but
then they lose it early some people hits
them late and they keep it for a
lifetime i mean it's it's always it's
always a different path so right you
know so when you give your two-week
notice um you know at the assistant job
and then i believe you know you come
across the davey rothbart article and
they're sort of a six month window there
where you know you're trying to acquire
the rights from dave so how are you
supporting yourself in that window of
time you know by you know giving up your
work i mean did you have some sort of
funds you were leaning on during that
time i did i i was working as an editor
and um actually the producer of the film
cookie she uh she
she was creating a lot of videos for
non-profit organizations and
incorporations and such and needing
needing an editor so i was able to pick
up a lot of work and cut some nasa
videos and you know just corporate stuff
that you know it plays at a convention
you know and then they pop in a dvd for
you know whatever it might be
prospective investors and such and um so
i was able to sort of keep keep going
that during that time editing is a
really good job to have to sort of you
know keep is usually you can find some
kind of jobs out there that pay decently
and you make your own hours and you can
work out at home and it's it's a really
good job to have if you're trying to
write and put a film together and a lot
of filmmakers i know are editors and
they're off time mm-hmm
you know and we're talking about you
know making films you know making that
next film
do you have any fear about not being
able to make another film
does that ever come into mind i think
every single night i uh i dream of not
making another film you know it's
definitely i mean some days i some days
i feel like oh i have like the world at
my fingertips the other days i'm like i
still have to like dig to china you know
like i'm trying to trying to still work
really hard you know i just try to
remind myself like i still have to
really i still have to prove myself
every step of the way you have to and um
some you know once in a blue moon it
comes easy to someone and they get a
their movie plays at a festival and they
get a tv deal and they get a production
deal with a major producer and such and
um and that's great but you can't expect
that or wait for that especially in the
way things are now so yeah i don't i
don't you know all i'm trying to do is
sort of stay ahead of that and generate
as much material um
you know i'm trying to learn i get
really
i get too emotionally involved with
projects too early on and just want to
get them made no matter what which is a
great feeling to have but i'm also
realizing i need to diversify i need to
have like more projects so that there's
more of an opportunity for something to
happen soon i'm trying to do that to
write something that's really cheap
right something that's sort of medium
right something that maybe i could it
could just be a script i sell you know
i'm trying to
to do that but it's it's tough because
you kind of have to put your mind in all
these different places to balance them
all that's a lot of work as well yeah
but it's but it can be fun you know
writing a script if it's
can be quick if you have the right idea
and you're in the right mind state you
can write a script really quick so
now kyle we remember you fondly from
last year's spirit awards and we were in
the press tent and we remember how you
addressed the crowd and you were very
humble and gracious and we're just
curious how that night was for you um it
was really really surreal uh it was
really one actually it's like it's
almost a year now since and um
and it was really you know it's one of
those things um i feel really actually
going back i feel lucky uh this year
they're not
they're not giving out the award live
during the broadcast they gave it during
a luncheon i think in consideration of
that they're gonna air like a two-minute
clip of the film that won the award
which in some ways is even more
advantageous because you get all this
your film gets even a little bit more
exposure but for us it was i i a friend
of mine invited me and i went with him
the year before and i just felt like
oh this is so distant you know i had my
film was finished and we were about to
play the festival but i was like this
feels so far away and it was um it was
really humbling and like overwhelming to
be there and to go
and then to be on stage and and trying
to give a speech that makes sense and
also realizing that you don't want to be
listing people off you know doing that
thing and it was it was odd i don't
really remember it i kind of blanked out
a bit and um but i was grateful that
afterwards that they had like a thank
you camera so i could say thank you to
like the people i i forgot to thank
especially like the guy whose life it's
based on so um uh but then and then
afterwards yeah and the press it was
just it was weird but it was a really
good feeling and and i just felt really
uh grateful for the you know exposure it
gave the movie and you know the
opportunities it gave it gives me now to
to get my scripts out there and you know
actors are more interested and it's it's
i've always i've always joked that the
the only thing that the city cares more
about than money is is awards and so um
i i personally you know that what i care
about in the awards is how much everyone
else cares about them you know like to
me that's what's great about it is like
okay now people are like oh you want a
spirit award let me read this script
first or whatever it might be and i'm
grateful for what that gave me and i'm
also grateful that film independent has
managed to keep the spirit awards like a
place for for discover for film
discoveries i mean for best first
feature
that year there were so many all the
movies there had done so well at the box
office and everything and for them to
say we're going to throw this movie and
then no one's heard of you know um or
that so few people have compared to
crazy heart and mess in the messenger
and paranormal activity and such i'm i'm
really grateful that they did that and
they've done that again this year and
that they that their you know their
nominating committees have gone
out of their way to make sure that it
lives up to its name of being called the
independent spirit awards you know it's
not just movies that were made
independently but movies that have been
struggling and working their way up the
festival or out i think i think they've
kept the integrity of the the ceremony
which i really like on a side note um we
had um alex holdridge the director of in
search of a midnight kiss on in 2009 i
just met him the first time at a spirit
wars luncheon i'd never met him before
but i was i like sought him out because
i know that i know scoot from the film
and i never met alex yeah yeah very cool
yeah great guy great interview and you
know he won the cassavetes award at the
2009 um spirit awards and he mentioned
that despite all the fanfare and hoopla
that went along with it that you know i
think he addressed the crowd and he said
you know i'll still be taking the trash
out in the morning at my restaurant job
and i think they even put that in a
newspaper headline like you know alex
won't have to take the trash out in the
morning to which he did and and his
restaurant manager i think posted it up
so in in saying this how was life
different for you after the spirit
awards and how had really nothing
changed
um well i mean
nothing really changed i don't alex has
a studio deal
which is great for him and awesome and
it's it's a great project and um
uh you know i you know in some ways i'm
it's changed in that i've been able to
go into some of those meetings i have
been able to pitch on studio films and
and you know do my damn just on them and
i bring in books and storyboards and do
the whole the whole
you know rigmarole of um i know i just
printed mispronounced that word um of of
of pitching movies to a student which
has been like an amazing experience
whether a studio project comes my way
anytime in the near future or not it's
such to go in and try to describe to
someone on these big much bigger budget
projects what you want to do you know
has been amazing and i do think the
spirit awards but in the ways it hasn't
changed is i'm still
i have my passion project and i'm still
pushing it and i'm still
you know emailing everyone i know i'm
still trying to find the money for it
and dig it up it hasn't it hasn't been a
golden ticket but it certainly helps in
terms of
it's a it's a nice thing to have in the
first sentence of your bio you know you
know we have richard purvis calling in
okay and let's just see if we have him
here richard richard are you with us
right now
hey guys hey i'm being uncle welcome to
film courage richard um you know do you
have a question for kyle
i do have a question for kyle um
for your first feature film
how did you find the the casting process
uh because
the reason i ask is is because actually
i'm in the middle of the casting process
right now for a feature film that i'm
putting together
and
in order to get the cast together you
tend to find that they say well do you
have the money and then you go to the
money people and they say do you have
the cast and the sales agent
and then the sales agent says do you
have the cast in place so i was
wondering
how what was your approach to sort of
get past that uh unholy triangle
well actually i'm in the process of that
right now with my project cog where
everyone's like well who do you have
involved and then you go to the
actors we want we go to their agents and
they're like well what money it's this
it's the same thing it's this weird
conundrum on my first film
i specifically went out and saw money i
saw prior you know individual investment
money that was non-cost contingent um
which is really you know it's really
hard to find and you know it was
pre-economic difficulties at least you
know in the us and
um it was a little easier to find but
you know from for me it was always
really important that i wouldn't have to
rely and it's still really important to
me that i wouldn't have to rely on on a
big name or a star or something to
justify the financing because i think
that's a little bit of a a slippery
slope and doesn't always lead to the
best films sometimes it does but not
always unfortunately uh i have to agree
with you but i'm actually stuck on that
slippery slope right now so
oh well never mind no you know i mean i
wish i had i wish i had a more direct
answer but it definitely
it's that that honestly that's the game
i mean that unless you have a really
specific like a genre picture or horror
movie
because i'm kind of doing a thriller
right now where
casting isn't as essential to the the
prophets of the film it can be
i you know i i wish i had a more direct
answer but it was on my first film we
were fortunate enough to find the kind
of financing
that people that understood that we
wanted to just find the right actors um
but you know this time around when we
need some more money yeah it is we're
trying to you know what does help is if
you know i find the actors if you can
it's about getting past the their
blockade so if you it's like if you can
get them the script i i have a lot of
respect for actors they're usually
really gutsy and they'll take a chance
if they respond to the material and i
find traditionally speaking actors trust
their gut and so it's a matter of trying
to find a way to get them the material
um yeah that was actually going to be my
next question how much of
your casting process was sort of
was basically yeah personal contact
rather than going through their agents
because obviously that's the big
stumbling block i've got right now is
the big blockade that is the actor's
agent yeah that's you know that's well
on the first film we just held we didn't
cast anyone who didn't read so everyone
auditioned for the film no one no one
got cast in the film who did an audition
so that was just an audition process
where you know we had casting directors
and they sent the script out to the
agencies and then they sent people in
and we just had big days where you know
dozens of people come in and read um on
my new on my film cog now
uh we are just you know we're having to
ask agents and it is hard we do have
sometimes it gets passed on and we get
lucky um other times we know it doesn't
get passed on and we just get a
rejection um you know and we do say hey
you know we're trying to
you know and some people some investors
you know that our producers will be like
oh you have too many people attached i
wanted to be a part of casting and for
me i'm like right now i just want to
build as many elements around my film so
yeah it's a matter of you know sometimes
it is a personal connection i find the
best is a combination you know you go to
the agents you do the proper informal
thing but then you ask around and you
find out who might
know someone who might be able to put in
a good word for you or at least get that
person that talent to the point where
they're going to ask their age and be
like hey someone asked me about this
project have you gotten that yet so then
the agent has to send them the script
now because if not then they wouldn't be
doing their job so it's so you have to
sort of play that you do have to play
the game a little bit and play both
sides to to try to succeed
but it helps to be in la to do it well
that that's for sure because i mean what
i've always said when people ask me oh
should i move to la or not i'm like if
you know what i totally respect the
people especially like a lot of the guys
in austin and seattle who are just doing
their own thing completely and working
with local actors and such but um
otherwise the advantage of being in la
is like you just go to someone's house
that's a party and you meet someone
who's an actor and then you're like oh i
kind of like that person maybe i'll do a
short film with them or or you're you
know whatever it might be there's just
it almost to the point of exhaustion
everyone's involved in the industry so
the chances of meeting people or meeting
someone who might know someone who might
know someone who knows
whoever is is is um
raise your chance of that happening yeah
absolutely and i have to say it's
exactly the same this side of the pond
in the uk as well if you're based
outside of london which i am then you
encounter the exact same difficulties so
it's nice to know i'm not the only one
yeah it you know it's it's true and and
sometimes it's a matter of really i do
find that actors respond to if you have
a film or a short you know i've seen a
lot of times
that you know name actors just they
really they're like oh i really like
that short i want to work with that guy
and i find that i find the actors really
are i mean i say that really positively
because you know people can always say
whatever they will about actors but i do
find that actors are really willing to
go out there and take a risk if they
feel it's going to be give them an
opportunity opportunity to do something
so it's just a matter of trying to get
to them and and finding a way um
a way away in
okay right well that's great thank you
very much yeah best of luck
all right guys have a good rest of your
day same to you yeah likewise yeah thank
you that was richard pervez calling from
across the pond here
on film cards and nellytalkradio.com
it's great to hear the accent come in
you know
he's not he's nonsense factory on
twitter and we've had a lot of exchanges
there so it's great to have them call in
here
um you know if you want to call in the
numbers la talk radio 2 on skype
um kyle you know going back to easier
with practice
and and sort of this budget range that
you're working it's somewhere and i'm
just guessing you know you don't have to
necessarily answer i know it's it's less
than a million i imagine it's somewhere
still six figures
you know but that's a lot of
responsibility for a first-time feature
filmmaker
to take on that kind of money and sort
of carry out the the this vision that
you have for the film
um
you know what do you have to say about
you know
take you know because you know you're
not starting with just like a 50 000
film or or cheaper you're starting with
with a it's a pretty heavy duty film for
you for your first one yeah it was
definitely intimidating um
and definitely something i'm i'm you
know but at the same time that i was
grateful that we had that we got that
experience of like the full production
crew and yeah we were definitely under
we're definitely under a million um but
we uh that you know we weren't like we
weren't applicable for the john
cassavetes award which i think is under
500 i believe 400. so that that gives
you an idea of our range um i guess i
was trying to get out what gave you the
confidence yeah that you could take out
a project of that magnitude for your
first your first remember i remember
asking my my dad who used to be in
business once and um
and was you know had to work on some big
deals and i was like how do you do how
do you deal with that how do you wrap
your mind around that and he was like i
just cut i just cut a few zeros off the
end you know so it was kind of like okay
i would look at it and be like okay this
is a fifty thousand dollar decision we
would have to make like okay if it's
wherever we're gonna low shoot location
or the car rig or whatever it might be
and let's just say our five thousand i'd
be like okay if this was out of my own
pocket and i had
it was 500 decision or 50 decision would
i take it or not as opposed to the fight
you know just to try to make it relative
and trust your instincts that way and
still go off of financial and just
always staying true we made sure every
penny was well spent you know and that
was something that was really important
to me and my producer to be like we're
not gonna waste a penny but it was
really intimidating and there was one
day only one day we went past our you
know the 12-hour like union mark and
we'd kind of planned for it but i
remember someone pulled out a chart and
i saw it and it said pat like every
literally every minute the money that
was being spent every minute that passed
and it was like oh my god you know it
was it was the one moment that i like
had to kind of push even go past the ads
and be like we have to get this it was
back in film school we were like i don't
know what we want to do we just grab the
camera and we're like maybe we'll put it
behind the sofa okay move the sofa
forward and the sun was rising and
literally like hundreds and hundreds of
dollars thousands of dollars were
getting spent every passing minute and
it was it was definitely stressful but
um but yeah you just kind of had to you
kind of have to uh lie to yourself and
tell yourself it's not as much money as
it actually is
you know and you also kind of joke
around that you know you raised the
financing for this film at a time where
the money was there you know and and
since the you know the the downturn in
the economy but but how did you go about
raising the money for the film honestly
it was uh it was just a matter i i took
a class at film independent they have a
lot of great classes and this guy too
pollard who's uh financed his own films
and financed some other people's not him
personally but has found financing uh he
taught a class on on business planning
and it was like you know i think it was
like four weeks and you would go in it
was like three hours once a week and
um and he basically would go through and
be like okay this is you have to build
this is your legal stuff you have to do
you have to build this it's gonna be
this many pages it should say stuff like
this and this is what you should look
out for in terms of investors which you
should be wary of and um and it was a
matter of and everyone there had
projects in different ranges some people
were looking for documentaries for a
couple hundred thousand dollars other
people were looking for features that
were a few million dollars it was all
different but
but the
methodology was all the same in terms of
okay the industry itself and by that i
mean studios or even the small
production companies aren't interested
in you so where do you get that money
from and you know it's about finding
it's about networking really was for me
was just like
every day i probably sent 50 emails to
people just asking like hey do you know
anyone do you know anyone that maybe has
some money that's maybe interested do
you know anyone that loves movies or
like if you're shooting in a specific
part of the country do you do you guys
know anyone there you think back on all
your family or cousins or whatever it is
and i'm doing that now with with my uh
david sadera's project which is i'm you
know i'm just eating it's like we're
gonna shoot in a specific state so i'm
asking every i know i knew someone
through someone who's a real estate
agent there so i emailed them hey do you
know anyone here's our business plan
here in my bios and this is the script
and and you know it's it can be
disheartening a little bit because it is
it is essentially it is essentially
begging and that's i mean it's a hard
thing to do i think for anybody um
maybe not anybody but um it is for me
but it is but it is a process of just
being like hoping that
it might be five steps five tiers down
the road but that someone's gonna be
like oh yeah you know what i have some
money that would be kind of fun or i i
need to write some money off of my taxes
this year or i need some losses and
that's why it was easier back then
because
you know people needed to get some money
off their hands nowadays it's a little
bit harder but it is imagine it is a
part of like breaking through and just
trying to find those few people but also
being careful that they're not the type
of you know you want to know where is
your limit where are they well does the
scene have to happen this way or can my
daughter be in it or whatever it might
be and you're always going to have to
make concessions you're never going to
get perfect money there's always going
to be something you're going to have to
say okay yeah you know what that's a
small part and we'll just put a little
extra time in the shooting schedule to
make sure that guy's daughter can
deliver the lines well you know i mean
you you you you can you have to make
exceptions but you have to know where
your threshold is of saying i don't want
to make this movie anymore cheaply or
these are the things that are important
to me i won't change and i'd just rather
not make the film than than make it with
those things being different
especially to probably outside of
california there's more chance of people
being excited about something whereas in
l.a it's just like oh okay well we know
that there's fees involved how much do i
get whereas probably other parts of the
country it's different absolutely i
usually you usually hear about those
kind of crazy angel investors like those
stories in the movies where just someone
sits down and writes a six million
dollar check i think that's how like get
low got financed i believe that was from
california money but um
they spent years and years even with
robert duvall attached couldn't get the
money couldn't get the money and the
producer sat down with someone once and
the guy at the end of the lunch the guy
wrote the check wow he was like i think
it was like as long as i can go golfing
with robert duvall one day and like
that's kind of what it was
and that's robert duvall but i mean i
hear stories of that every day that just
someone you know but it's a matter of
being sincere and being honest and just
being like film is a risky i i've heard
stories of people going out they're
trying to be like this is going to be
big my big fat greek wedding and you're
only going to put in 200 000 but you're
going to make 20 million it's just like
no you can say that might happen you
know that's my opinion i say this it
might happen but it's a total gamble you
have to put it in if we're talking about
really offbeat projects without any
major actors without any instantly
sellable qualities that are at risk you
know you say that could happen
especially now after sundance this past
year and all the sales you know or this
past month
but you also say you know what it could
very well you might not see a penny back
and you have to be okay with that as an
investor and if you're not and it's you
don't want someone needing their money
back because that's not a place then
that's when you feel that pressure on
set or when you feel that pressure at
the festival and it starts to wear down
on you and you feel uh it's crippling
right right someone taking out a second
mortgage or something yeah you have to
finance your phil let's go back real
quickly to the festivals that you did
not get into
what were you going through what was on
your mind when you were rejected by was
it sundance south by southwest tribeca
and berlin berlin um actually we never
applied to venice because by then we'd
already gotten to i mean you know
obviously sundance and south by were the
the big you know disappointments and we
yeah we felt like okay i didn't
understand it at the time i didn't
understand festivals and really how they
work and yeah every once in a while you
know they film breaks through but
most of the films that those big
festivals are businesses and they say
this respectfully because actually i've
since gotten to know a lot of the
sundance people and they work their
asses off to try to get films they love
in and but you know they're also running
a business so yeah if it's got a movie
star who's gonna show up like they've
gotta you know and they owe someone a
favor or whatever it might be like the
exposure is also important that's how
they can have the room for those films
so you're talking about thousands of
films being submitted
and then you're talking about only a few
amount of slots because so many of those
slots are taken up already by the films
that are just gonna get in no matter
even before they're made they're in you
know and um
and realizing those odds uh how much and
i don't even say that i always tell
people plan for sundance finish your
movie and time by august to get it in
but don't rely you know don't expect it
just plan for it make sure your film is
shot make sure it's at least mixed so
that you can follow the story all of
that so you can get in any time because
you have a chance at getting in but
don't you know don't expect it don't be
you know because that for me i i did not
that i expected it to come to me but i
really thought we had a real and
ultimately the positive side of it was
that
um the guys who run cinevegas where our
premiere was
were that doesn't it sadly doesn't exist
anymore were sundance programmers and
they saw my film in the committees the
programming committees at sundance when
it was being considered and when it
didn't get picked up that's when they
emailed me for the film festival that's
when they emailed me and said hey would
you be interested in this festival and
that ended up sort of being the saving
grace for our film so there's always a
positive side to it there's always
people you know those programmers as
much as you can be bitter about them
they they care some probably even more
than you do about your film playing at
the festival so
you know we have time for a quick call
here from kathleen donahue who's calling
in the film courage with a question for
kyle kathleen are you there yeah i'm
here can you hear me yes we can yes
welcome to film courage you have a
question for kyle yeah i can place an
accent if you want you know if that
helps
which one which ones can you do
well i was wondering you had mentioned
um that you had
a the biopic that you did
um based on a guy's life and i was
wondering if you
if you ran into any problems as far as
um
legal hurdles to to
leap over because i'm kind of doing the
same thing and i'm i wondered if you had
his permission or if you had to get
permission from other people if
in financing the film if that was an
issue yeah you know it's it's really
complex what happened was it was an
article in gq that was autobiographical
so i optioned the article and then with
that in that legal paperwork of course
came it was the rights to the story and
it was his story
um it is a really tricky thing and i
made the mistake of signing it
fortunately ended up not being any
problem with the film but i signed a
contract you know this option contract
without having a lawyer look over it you
know i thought oh i mean i learned the
legalese terms i understood the contract
but it still was no matter what at the
end of the day even if you're asking a
favor of a friend if you don't always
have a lawyer read something before you
sign it
and understand the project and you know
it is it is definitely a tricky place
and there's always going to be risks
involved but i did have his permission
um and i did have the legal rights to
his article and i'm i'm doing another
another thing now based on a short story
that's also autobiographical this this
david sedaris project and it's a similar
thing you know you have to make sure you
know this time i had the lawyers i'd
worked with you know that i now now know
and they looked over and that you know
they're there to protect you in that
sense um
yeah definitely make sure there's
someone helping you that understands it
a bit because it can be really tricky
and be the kind of thing that you could
get really far down the line
and then
you realize oh an important part of the
story you're not allowed to talk about
or you have to change an important
aspect of it to make sure it doesn't
you know but there's a lot of gray areas
in it and that's why i always encourage
um some kind of legal help because
um both positive and negative there you
know there's some things where it's like
well if you change a name you change a
location and occupation then you they
can't claim to be a part of the story
anymore but there's a lot of if ands or
buts and awkward places in there
interesting were you advised to um
fictionalize any part of it because of
that
because of potential problem you know i
i actually even just on a creative level
sort of superseded that because it
wasn't really anything historical i
really just liked the story it was
actually part of my pitch to the guy it
was based on that i wanted to change his
last name i didn't want
his uh creative work he tours of the
country with this magazine that's pretty
popular called found and i didn't even
think that that needed to be a part of
the story so sort of part of my
intentions and same with the sedaris
project were to just take the story and
put it into a structure and build a film
around it um so that sort of ended up
superseding that as opposed to it
actually me being like oh no i want to
tell a really true to life historical
retelling of this guy's life so i was
already changing names and and doing all
those things just out of a personal
place so i never really came across
those difficulties you know we're coming
down to our final five minutes here on
film curse that was kathleen donahue
calling and we want to thank you
kathleen for giving us a call here great
hearing from you as we wrap up today's
show now you're working on two other
projects which you briefly touched on
cog and girls yeah so girls is a project
i wrote with my good friend adam um i
wrote well c-o-g i'll make it really
fast because i know we're running a cog
is this it's a david sader story from
from naked and david's always been
really opposed to films he's said no to
films he said no to tv series out of his
work in the past and for 10 years i've
loved this specific story and his cold
feet has always been around his the
portrayal of his family and this story
that i happen to love that i happen to
think would make a perfect film a great
film
didn't involve any of his family and so
it took a long time we were speaking
about like you know getting past agents
and getting to the source the real
person and it really just came short of
me showing up at a book reading of his
and handing him a copy of my film and
saying hey i have some stuff i want to
talk to about uh to make it happen but
it did take about two and a half years
and i got the rights to that and now
we're in the process of trying to cast
it and get the money like we were
talking about earlier i'm still going
through that thing of we don't have the
money we want to get the actors so we're
having to talk around the agents and not
around them but talk to them and try to
get them to understand hey just share
with them you know this could be a
really viable project it's difficult too
um and then girls a totally different
experience um
which is that we so we sat down in the
summer while i was waiting for people to
read the sedera script and said let's
just write something that can be cheap
and fun and scary and we could make
quickly and but still be really creative
and ambitious and difficult to pull off
and um and we sat down we wrote the
script really fast and thinking that we
were going to have to raise a little bit
of money for ourselves and people
responded really really well to it it
was actually we're talking about all
this sort of stuff away from the
industry and how difficult it is and how
many things you have to circumvent but
this was a time
that was totally different for me i gave
it to my agents they read it they really
liked it um and they sent it out to like
a dozen people they thought might like
it and like three of those people wanted
to do it i met with them
and then you know one of them i got
along with the most and he totally got
the project and that's uh peter safran
who produced buried and um and now we're
making the film in may so you know by
the time the film is done in
post-production it will have been less
than a year between thinking of the idea
and shooting the film and part of that
is because it's a thriller and i think
that um
don't never underestimate the power of
genre and that kind of exposure that can
give you as long as you make sure you're
you're keeping what you like and about
as yourself as a filmmaker intact which
i believe i am so it's going to be a fun
simple thriller but i think it's still
going gonna have my imprint on it and um
and i'm getting an opportunity to do
something completely insane that
someone's trusting me to do and i'm it's
gonna be a lot of fun it's been it's
been an absolute pleasure having you
here thank you studio and thank you for
everyone who's listening and especially
the people who called in yeah absolutely
and that was richard purbess and
kathleen donahue thank you both and also
i thought it was really nice to see
valerian zamel write in on facebook you
know easier with practice is an amazing
film all capitals
you know we'd love to see that um highly
recommend our audience go back in and
and check out easier with practice
wherever you can
absolutely yeah it's on netflix instant
uh domestically and it's uh i believe
actually just it comes out on dvd in the
uk
uh and on i think on valentine's day and
i think they're holding a special
screening in the uk at a special like
anti-valentine's day screening of the
movie because it's kind of a romance but
it's kind of not so all right we've been
speaking with writer director of the
film easier with practice kyle patrick
alvarez for more on kyle please visit
easierwithpractice.com at kyle alvarez
on twitter
facebook.com
kyle alvarez and on imdb thank you again
kyle for spending your super bowl sunday
with us we appreciate it thank you guys
thank you and david and karen signing
off from this week's film courage thank
you for being with us again on the super
bowl sunday and also we could not end an
episode of film courage without a huge
thank you to our friend tech engineer
and webmaster ronan rosner
roninbuiltfilmcourage.com for us and he
runs the board here at la talk radio and
until next sunday have a great week